today we're going to
discuss bioenergetics continue that
discussion
and use that as a transition into
also beginning to see how that applies
to understanding
glycolysis the pathway that allows
glucose
breakdown so just as a reminder of a
couple of the points that we
discussed last time and so last time we
discussed what makes reactions favorable
and so
remember you could have any reaction a
to b a to b
could be a single step a to b could be
an entire pathway
all steps in the pathway that whether or
not
that reaction or pathway happens is
determined by thermodynamics it's not
determined by enzymes
enzymes are important of course to
control the rate of reactions
so they may allow things to happen that
otherwise wouldn't happen
but whether the reaction happens or not
is determined by
free energy and so free energy delta g
remember we discussed
is the following relationship so it's
related to this
constant delta g naught prime which is
related to the equilibrium constant
for any pair of products and reactants
as well as this formula rt times the log
of the
products over the reactants and so
remember this means that whether a
reaction happens depends on the
equilibrium constant
but it also depends on the actual
conditions present that is
how much substrate and how much product
is there
and so what this means is is that
biology can come up with ways
by keeping the product concentrations
low to do things that may
move in the opposite direction of what
you would predict
from equilibrium and also by coupling
these less favorable reactions to more
favorable reactions you can also
allow biology to do unfavorable stuff
and this is of course where the role of
atp comes in
and we discuss this at the end of last
time as well
of course atp what's important then
becomes
the ratio of atp to adp
and to illustrate that we use this
example right we use that remember atp
hydrolysis has a delta g not prime of
minus 7.5 kcals per mole that of course
tells you this is about the equilibrium
constant that tells us the equilibrium
lies to the right
we can couple it to this first reaction
in glycolysis which traps glucose in the
cell by adding a phosphate group
delta g not prime for this is positive
3.3 k cals per mole
this positive number tells you that the
equilibrium
lies towards the left but when we couple
these two reactions together
we add these two numbers together and
now we get a delta g naught prime of
minus 4.2 k cals per mole
which says of the coupled reaction the
equilibrium lies now again to the right
and that's how we can use atp hydrolysis
in order to carry out this unfavorable
process
trapping the glucose in the cell now how
much
glucose will be trapped well of course
that will come from this reaction up
here
and that's because whether or not a
reaction occurs or not of course depends
not on the equilibrium constant
but on the actual conditions and the
delta g
of that reaction and so we can just plug
that in for this system and so we see
delta g not prime minus 4.2 k cals per
mole
that says equilibrium lies to the right
but how far
really depends on the conditions and
that's defined by
this ratio of products over reactants
and you can imagine that this term
here as long as it's less than 4.2 you
will favor
glucose trapping inside the cell
whereas of course if it's greater than
4.2 then you'd favor
the the opposite direction would be
favorable
now this is really critical
because this really explains how it is
that
atp actually works to help cells
do various do do various reactions
and so if an atp adp ratio exists
such that it can make delta g less than
zero for the reaction that it's coupled
to
that is how it provides the energy that
then allows
unfavorable reactions to occur and so
please do not make the common mistake
that many many biologists make
when they state oh atp equals energy
there's a lot of atp
the cell must have a lot of energy
remember it's the ratio
of atp to adp that provides the energy
and so that means atp
can be sky high but if adp is equally
high
there's no energy there consequently
atp can be very low but if adp is
extremely low
now you still have a high atp to adp
ratio
and that is what provides the energy and
that's because this occurs regardless of
concentration it's because this it's
this ratio
of atp to adp that ultimately
says how much energy is there for the
atp to drive
a reaction in other words delta g
for whatever the reaction is coupled to
is going to be proportional
to the ratio of adp to atp
great now how much atp
do you need then what ratio do you need
to drive a reaction
well it's hard to say that in absolute
terms because it's going to be defined
by
how that ratio is coupled to the ratio
of whatever other
reactants and products it also tells you
remember
as we talked about before we can switch
the directions of these reactions and we
just flip the signs the directions here
are arbitrary and so that means it also
tells us how much energy we need to put
in
if we're going to charge up an atp
adp ratio in other words if we want to
synthesize
atp that is take adp plus
phosphate and make an atp
well what's this well we just exact
opposite sign of that delta g not prime
is going to now equal
plus 7.5 kcals
per mole okay and so
that means that the equilibrium of this
reaction
is going to lie to the left okay just as
that one lied to the right
and it's going to lie to the left by
that much
and if we want to know how much energy
it then takes to make
atp well obviously it's not going to
happen because equilibrium favors this
direction it's not spontaneous in that
direction
but at various conditions we can know by
plugging in our formula
delta g equals delta g not prime plus
7.5 k
cals per mole plus
rt times the log of atp
so if i have my adp
i'm sorry my atp concentration
sufficiently low
relative to my adp concentration i can
still make this
reaction happen now that's not going to
give you an atp adp ratio that is
actually consistent with
being able to do anything else into the
cell and so but what it says is
is that if i am able to
couple energy from nutrient metabolism
to this reaction and overcome
this positive 7.5 k cals per mole that
basically
will allow me to now synthesize atp
and maintain an atp adp ratio in the
cell
that allows cells to carry out
other functions by the same rules that
we talked about that would be
unfavorable
now there's lots of implications here
for metabolism because it says how much
input
you need to synthesize atp how much
energy you need to synthesize
atp is going to depend on how charged
this ratio is
and how useful that ratio is to catalyze
other reactions
is also going to be depend on how
charged
that ratios is and in essence this is
why we cannot store
energy as atp this is why we didn't eat
atp for breakfast
and instead ate cereal that has a bunch
of glucose in it because we can use that
glucose to get atp
but the atp itself is not something that
we really can burn
to get energy in a sustained way in
other words
the delta g of atp
synthesis okay making atp
is going to be proportional to the log
of the ratio of atp
over adp for all the reasons i described
the delta g of using atp atp hydrolysis
using atp to drive reactions is also
proportional to rt times the log in this
case of the adp
to atp ratio okay
and so because you need to consume this
ratio to get energy
and you need to put in ratio to put in
energy to
create this ratio you are constant and
how much
is an exponential property you are
constantly
having to generate atp in a way that
allows you to then have a ratio that can
then be consumed
to fuel other reactions and that's
what's shown here on the slide so i just
graphed here what the atp adp ratio is
relative to a theoretical delta g it's
shown here as a
um you know on a linear scale here on a
log scale that basically basically
there's this logarithmic relationship
and so you need an exponential increase
in energy input
to drive this ratio up higher in order
to
quote unquote store more energy that can
be used for later
and so this system is not one that you
can use as an energy storage system
and ultimately explains why cells have
to do constant metabolism have to
constantly
do some sort of metabolism to keep this
atp adp ratio
charged for it to be in a useful range
to have an atp adp ratio that can be
coupled to drive
otherwise unfavorable reactions in our
cells
right so to say this another way our
cells need to constantly catabolize
nutrients
burn glucose burn some other fuel they
have to do this
because they have to keep that ratio
charged in a range
where that can then support other cell
functions
allow them to fight entropy and maintain
order in biology
we alluded last time if you stop making
atp
well what's going to happen well that
atp adp ratio the cell has
is going to fuel whatever reactions it
can do until suddenly that ratio falls
below the point where it's useful
to drive those unfavorable reactions in
fact if you stop
atp production you will consume that atp
adp ratio
in seconds and this is why if you poison
atp production
cells die very quickly remember last
time we mentioned
you have a heart attack blood flow stops
going to a tissue no more nutrients and
oxygen
cells die quickly cyanide poisoning does
the same thing
cells die quickly if you stop their
ability to maintain
this atp adp ratio in the right range
and so remember the concentration the
absolute concentration of atp for these
reasons
is not a good indicator of cell energy
the correct
indicator of cell energy is the ratio
of atp to adp okay
this term is sometimes referred to as
the
energy charge
okay and so that can be the atp
to adp ratio or often times more
correctly
is the atp to amp
ratio why the atp to amp ratio
well that's because once you understand
this you can now understand that cells
have a fail-safe mechanism
to protect themselves if this ratio of
atp to adp becomes too low
what is that mechanism well you can
carry out this reaction
take two adp molecules and turn them
into
transfer a phosphate to make an atp
plus an amp why is that a fail-safe
mechanism well
if they care about this if the atp adp
ratio is what maintains your ability
to drive these thermodynamically
unfavorable reactions
if i sacrifice the denominator by
removing an adp
and get an atp out of it i've now at
least temporarily fixed
that ratio now this is something that
obviously cannot go on forever
but in the short term it does allow
cells
to protect that ratio and in fact what
cells
actually defend is this atp amp ratio
and it's very very difficult to change
the atp
amp ratio in a cell and actually have it
live so it's really this atp amp ratio
that is
most formally related to what would be
caused
called energy charge but this is really
um why this is important is for all the
reasons that i just
described all right so hopefully
it's clear to you now why cells
have to keep atp adp ratio in the right
range
why this is useful for them to now carry
out all of these unfavorable reactions
fight entropy
stave off death but
and they can even have us fail safe here
and a deep sacrifice adp
is a way to try to maintain that as a
very last
resort it also says why cells have to
always do catabolism because you always
need the energy input
to keep that ratio in the right range
however you might imagine that in real
life
the messiness of biology that there's
lots of situations where the demand for
atp
will suddenly increase well of course
maybe you can just metabolize more sugar
do more nutrient catabolism to try to
keep that ratio high
but that takes time and so you need
ways for cells to quickly respond to
then allow them to mobilize all of this
extra thing to extra fuel to do that
for example you know we're walking
around our ancestors on the plane
somewhere and a lion appears
we don't have time to mobilize a bunch
of new fuel we have to be able to run
away really quickly
or the lion's gonna eat us and so cells
have systems to suddenly respond to
i need a lot more atp demand to run away
by having ways that one can buffer
this atp adp ratio protect it in the
short term
and allow cells to time to ramp up
nutrient catabolism in order to keep
this high
all right well if we wanted to create
such a buffer system
how would we actually do it well
obviously we have to follow all the
rules of thermodynamics that we
discussed
and we have to do so in a way that
actually illustrates
how it is that very well how metabolism
works
in other words if suddenly the
atp adp ratio drops okay if we have a
sudden drop
in atp adp ratio because we have
increased demand needing to run away
from a lion
how could we actually create a buffer
system that protects
this well to do it we would need to
couple
atp adp to some other product reactant
pair let's call them
x and y such that the ratio of y
to x is coupled to the ratio
of atp to adp
and you want it coupled in such a way
that if that ratio goes down
this ratio can now protect atp basically
favor
atp to adp synthesis however
when nutrients are plentiful and this
ratio is really high
it then in turn can charge up this ratio
so that it can buffer it later when the
atp adp ratio comes
starts to fall now the example the most
famous example of this
actually comes from muscle physiology
and it's best described in terms of
muscles and how they quickly respond to
increased demand like that running away
from a lion
however it in fact applies to many many
cells
including most non-muscle cells in
animals all right and i should say that
it turns out that if you turn off atp
synthesis in a muscle
people have estimated that your atp adp
ratio will fall
into a range where it is no longer
useful to do anything
within a matter of seconds some claim
even less
than a second and so this system ends up
being
very important now the system that
muscle uses and many other cells do as
well
is something called the creatine
creatine phosphate
system now if you guys are weight
lifters or bodybuilders out there
you probably have heard of creatine
because it's a very popular supplement
that is taken
for weight lifting something i obviously
don't do a lot of
okay but that creatine creatine
phosphate
is out there i'll describe to you what
it actually does
for muscle cells and you can decide for
yourself if this is actually useful
as a energy or weightlifting supplement
okay so what is creatine creatine
phosphate what does it look like
okay well it's basically looks like this
by the way i will use this abbreviation
often throughout this course just as
shorthand to draw a lot of these
structures
so this here would be a carboxylic
acid group drawn like this
or like that okay drawn as a carboxylic
acid group
just so you understand my shorthand
okay so this here is the molecule
creatine if i put a phosphate here
this now becomes creatine phosphate
again just to remind you this p
with a circle over it is a phosphate
group i'll draw
this particular phosphate group because
it's a nitrogen
phosphate bond a phosphor amidate bond
this is actually a bond that is more
labile than the po bonds that we're used
to seeing in the phosphodiesters like
atp
etc okay all right so
that's creatine and creatine phosphate
and
if we draw out the reaction creatine
phosphate goes to
creatine plus inorganic phosphate so
hydrolysis of creatine phosphate this
has a delta g
not prime of minus 10
kcals per mole
what does that mean it's negative tells
us about the equilibrium constant
equilibrium
lies to the right remember atp to adp
hydrolysis
shown over there the that hydrolysis has
a delta g not prime of minus 7.5 k
cals per mole equilibrium also lies to
the right
this number is more negative this
equilibrium lies further to the right
than atp hydrolysis does okay
so now what happens if we couple this
reaction
to the atp hydrolysis reaction so now we
can do
atp plus creatine
to creatine phosphate
plus adp so we've coupled those two
reactions together
so delta g not prime atp to adp
is minus 7.5 creatine phosphate to
creatine
in that direction is negative 10
in this direction it would be positive
10
and so as i've drawn the reaction this
delta g naught prime will be
plus 2.5 k cals per mole
10 minus 7.5 plus 2.5
okay which tells us then that this
equilibrium now
lies to the left all right
however which direction this reaction
actually goes is not determined only by
the equilibrium it's also
it's really determined by delta g so we
can calculate that
so delta g equals delta g
not prime plus rt
log of as we've drawn it
creatine phosphate
over creatine and adp adp over atp
so you can now imagine that this term
here is the sum of those two so it's
plus
2.5 and so if this term
is less than
2.5 what does that mean
well if it's well sorry less than
negative 2.5
then delta g will be negative and you
will favor
creatine phosphate production if this
term
is greater than negative 2.5
then delta g will be positive and you
will favor
atp production why is that
important well if you think about the
conditions how you could make this term
less than 2.5 or
greater or less than negative 2.5 or
greater than negative 2.5
basically what's going to happen is is
that if the atp
adp ratio
is high all right lots of energy around
no problems charging up lots of things
to use
charge up this atp adp to a very high
ratio
well now you will favor this direction
creatine phosphate synthesis
however if atp
adp begins to fall and is lower
well now this term is going to flip
and you'll now favor atp production
and so basically by charging up this
creatine creatine phosphate ratio it now
creates a situation
where it can buffer that atp 80p ratio
so that when times are good you charge
up the buffer when times are bad
you then consume the buffer in a way
that
allows you to protect your atp adp ratio
for a short time
and this is illustrated very nicely here
in this slide that
basically shows what happens in muscle
physiology and so
this is just a theoretical curve that if
you suddenly need to contract your
muscle
and you stop atp production well atp
levels will fall that atp adp ratio more
correctly will fall rapidly within the
cell
creatine phosphate will then now kick in
to
protect that atp adp ratio as you can
ramp up
either anaerobic or aerobic metabolism
to now buffer
that atp adp ratio and keep that muscle
functioning
okay now i want to make one point
because oftentimes
biochemistry textbooks will refer to
things like
atp or creatine phosphate is quote
unquote high energy
compounds and of course i guess they are
high energy because they have these
labile
phosphate nitrogen or phosphate oxygen
bonds and because they're labile
hydrolysis is favorable and to a certain
extent
it's that hydrolysis that is providing
energy but remember it's not the
metabolite or the bond in isolation
that's really providing the energy it's
these ratios
of atp to adp creatine phosphate to
creatine
that allow you to couple for all the
reasons we've spent now a lecture and a
half discussing
two other reactions that really provides
biological energy
all right now we're ready to discuss
how it is that we can use glucose
oxidation
nutrient catabolism to keep atp
adp high that is in a useful range
where it can allow cells to do otherwise
thermodynamically
unfavorable things so how could we make
this
happen well just like this example
with creatine and creatine phosphate if
we want to use nutrient catabolism to do
the same thing
we need to couple reactions of glucose
oxidation nutrient catabolism
that will allow us to synthesize atp
adp to adp and have that synthesis be
favorable
despite the high atp adp ratio in cells
all right so let's think about it so
what is this nutrient catabolism what
did we talk about last time
oxidizing glucose to carbon and co2
right so here's our reaction for that
so here's carbohydrate glucose c6h2o6
plus 602. goes to
6 co2 plus
6 h2o that's the chemical formula for
whoops the chemical formula for burning
wood all right so delta g
not prime for this is minus 686
kcals per mole
quite a negative number equilibrium
greatly favors
the completely burned state
oxidized state of that carbohydrate
and so you can imagine that this
equilibrium is so favorable to the right
if we couple this reaction to atp
synthesis you're clearly going to have
plenty of energy there
in order to maintain that atp adp ratio
in the right range to be compatible with
cells using it to do other things
all right so how do we actually do that
well if we do it we have to follow the
same rules of thermodynamics
and do the same things that we did
before basically
we have to do this reaction
in a way that we can draw out a similar
type of equation as we did for creatine
and creatine phosphate
and at the highest level that is how
nutrient catabolism
will allow us to keep atp adp ratio high
even as atp hydrolysis is constantly
fueling
all these other unfavorable processes in
the cell
now if we did this all in one step our
burning wood
example lots of heat is generated
that's too much energy not so good for
biology
okay but rather what biology does
as we alluded to last time is that
because what we talked about in the
beginning that all of the things that we
discussed
are true for individual reactions or
many many reactions
basically if we turn a into b and we do
it in one step
like burning wood or we do it in 500
steps
the thermodynamic consequences are
exactly
the same and so what we need to do
is do stepwise catabolism of glucose
and take advantage of the fact that that
delta g change is the same
whether it's one step or many steps and
in that stepwise fashion
build in reactions where we create
intermediates intermediate chemistries
that allow us to do things like we did
with creatine and creatine phosphate
such that we can favor atp synthesis
when atp adp ratio is in the
physiological range
and in essence this is the magic of how
biology
does this and basically couples
of nutrient catabolism
in order to provide energy and so the
pathway that we're going to discuss
today and in the next lecture is
something called
glycolysis which simply put
is glucose
lysis it's the
stepwise chemical oxidation of glucose
which we know from our burning wood
example is favorable
and we're going to use this pathway
that basically will be a pathway to
allow the stepwise
lysis of glucose a favorable reaction
to individual steps that set it up in a
way such
that adp to atp synthesis is favored
despite a physiological atp adp
ratio now i want to point out that this
really illustrates back to that high
energy compound thing
that atp is not the only energy currency
in the cell in fact
glucose is much more energy for a cell
than atp you get much more energy
released
from burning wood than you get from
hydrolyzing atp
and in essence this is why we use
glucose why nature
has used glucose and other molecules
like it
as an energy storage device because
here's a relatively stable molecule can
sit around for a long time
and you can burn it when you need it to
keep your atp adp ratio
high all right so
at the level of reactions and pathways
now
how can we use glucose oxidation and
couple it to drive atp synthesis well
hopefully it's very clear
that we have to basically set up a
situation like this creatine creatine
phosphate system that we already
discussed and so i want to start
by discussing what are the two reactions
in glycolysis
that ultimately behave like this that
allow this favorable
atp adp to atp
synthesis and then we will go ahead and
consider
how we can make those reactions work
in the context of an entire pathway that
allows
glucose oxidation all right
now like
creatine phosphate and creatine
both of the steps in glycolysis that
favor atp synthesis
involve intermediates where you have
phosphate on some molecule
plus adp goes to
atp plus the phosphate coming off that
molecule
now if we go to our creatine creatine
phosphate system
obviously this equilibrium needs to lie
to the right and so the first one
of these is as follows
it involves this molecule phosphoenol
pyruvate
also referred to as pep you will see
throughout the course that
we love to give these little acronyms to
our metabolites because it's hard to
constantly say and write out
phospholinopyruvate
much easier to say pep so
phosphoenolpyruvate
plus adp goes to
atp plus if i take the phosphate off of
there
i get this molecule
this molecule is enol
pyruvate enol pyruvate
can be rearranged as follows
to make this molecule a ketone pyruvate
you'll note hopefully you remember from
your organic chemistry classes that
ketones like pyruvate can exist in two
forms that can exist in the ketone form
or the enol form rearranging by the
chemistry that i've shown
the keto form
is greatly favored
over the enol form
however by having a phosphate trap
pyruvate
in the enol form phosphoenolpyruvate
when you remove the phosphate and it's
wanting to exist in the keto form
greatly enhances the energetics of this
basically makes the reaction the
equilibrium want to lie
very far to the right and by the way
chemical tricks like this
and others like it you will see used
over and over
in biology in fact this is illustrated
if we ask what's delta g
not prime for this reaction it's minus
15 k cals
per mole that tells us that the
equilibrium of this reaction
lies to the right in fact it lies far to
the right
and in fact this is remember
atp hydrolysis is negative 7.5 kcals per
mole
so lies twice as far to the right as
atp hydrolysis does and in fact
this minus 15 kcals per mole is the
most favorable at least in terms of
individual reactions
that at least i know of in metabolism
all right well if this equilibrium for
this is pep
to pyruvate
this here is delta g not prime for atp
to 80p so if we want to know what's
delta g
not prime for the entire reaction
well if pep to pyruvate is minus 15
atp to 80p is well here we're going the
opposite
opposite direction so it'd be plus 7.5
so it's minus 15
plus 7.5 means that for the entire
reaction
this is minus 7.5 k
cals per mole means that this is
favorable equilibrium lies to the right
if we drew out i'm not going to do it
again because i've done it
a lot but if we redrew out this equation
replacing pyruvate and pep
in the correct places there for creatine
phosphate and creatine
you would see that there's lots of
conditions within cells that will favor
atp synthesis even when atp
adp ratio is high all right this
reaction
is catalyzed by an enzyme
called pyruvate kinase
and pyruvate kinase is a classic example
of a quote-unquote irreversible reaction
however i want to point out that the
enzyme pyruvate kinase
is actually named for the reverse
reaction that's supposedly irreversible
pyruvate kinase if you take pyruvate and
you act on the kinase as you learn from
professor yaffi
that phosphorylates something you
phosphorylate pyruvate you get
phosphoenolpyruvate
pyruvate kinase and so
remember that absolutely no reaction is
reversible
okay it's only revert what they mean by
irreversible when they say pyruvate
kinase step in glycolysis is
irreversible
is that it is effectively irreversible
under the conditions that are compatible
with life that exist in cells
of course if you have very low adp
and very high atp you can come up with a
way
to net synthesize pep
you just can't drive the reverse
reaction
under the atp adp and the pep pyruvate
ratios
that physiologically exist in cells
however this is set up in a way such
that
you can favor adp to atp synthesis
by converting pep to pyruvate in a
pathway as we will see happens in
glycolysis all right
now the second reaction
that i wanna that allows atp
synthesis in glycolysis
is catalyzed by an enzyme called phospho
glycerate
kinase okay and
this carries out the following reaction
okay so this molecule is one three
this phospho
glycerate abbreviated
1 3 bpg
c
and basically the phosphate is
transferred
from here to adp which gives you this
molecule
three phosphoglycerate
or three pg
okay so this reaction the delta g
not prime for the entire coupled
reaction
both steps of the reaction is minus 4.5
kcals per mole tells you about the
equilibrium constant equilibrium lies
to the right doesn't lie as far to the
right as the
pep plus adp goes to atp plus pyruvate
reaction
but nonetheless is one where there's
lots of conditions that are favorable in
cells to maintain a high atp adp ratio
although we will see later that this
reaction actually
runs quite close to equilibrium in cells
so there's actually conditions where it
can go in the opposite direction
as well and we'll get to that later in
the course
i want to point out one thing about this
one thing that makes this reaction
favorable as you notice here that this
is a
phosphate on an acid group a so-called
acid anhydride and this is a pretty good
phosphate donor
and so you want to lose that phosphate
which is
one of the reasons why this reaction is
favorable for
atp synthesis even at high atp
adp ratios all right so these are the
two reactions in glycolysis
that can favor atp synthesis at a high
atp adp ratio just like creatine and
creatine phosphate
and so hopefully now it's become
apparent to you
that if during our pathway of glucose
catabolism
we can build a pathway that couples
what we already know is favorable
glucose oxidation
to generate these intermediates pep and
1 3
bis phosphoglycerate we can then build a
pathway
where those reactions can make synthesis
of atp favorable
even though there's a high atp adp ratio
in cells
and in fact maintain that high atp adp
ratio in cells
and in essence this is the logic or the
goal if you will
of glycolysis and why it's important to
provide
energy to cells
okay
all right now if we're going to make
a pathway where glucose oxidation
is coupled to making pep and 1 3
bisphosphoglycerate
it's obvious we need to add phosphate
to the system there's no phosphate
molecule
on glucose all right i already mentioned
earlier and i just erased it that
to trap glucose in the cell
the first step in glycolysis you add
phosphate
okay but that phosphate donor is atp
and so atp being the phosphate donor
doesn't
help us here if we're going to use
phosphate transfer here we need to have
phosphate
added into the system if this is going
to work we can't
have atp as our phosphate donor you also
saw lots of reactions from professor
yaffi
that involved phosphate transfer
reactions
but again atp or gtp
is the phosphate donor and so
for this system to work we need a way
to get inorganic phosphate onto
a carbohydrate or we can't make things
like pep or 1 3 bisphosphoglycerate that
will allow
atp synthesis now i already
saw earlier that addition of phosphate
to glucose is not favored
right remember delta g not prime of
phosphorylating glucose was
plus 3.3 kcals per mole
and it turns out that says equilibrium
lies to the wrong side
so we can't net do that without atp or
energy
input and it turns out this is true for
other sugars as well
and so you need energy input to add
phosphate
to the sugars
plenty of energy input from glucose
oxidation
okay but we need a reaction where
phosphate addition is coupled to another
reaction that makes it favorable
and we have to do this without making
atp
and again it illustrates again that
biological energy is not just about atp
at a deeper level it's something
different
and so to really discuss this and
understand it
i need to introduce two concepts that
are going to come up again
over and over again in this class and
across
metabolism the first of these is a very
high level
bioenergetic concept although it's
really an energetic
concept and it comes back to what we
already talked about
so we know burning wood is favorable
all right
the cn
h2on
plus oxygen going to co2
plus water okay that's
burning wood lots of energy released
drew it up there for a single glucose
molecule and what the energy released
that
delta g naught prime is for that
reaction
now i want to point out chemically what
is going on
in this reaction chemically what is
happening
for this to occur is that electrons from
the carbon are being moved to the oxygen
you are changing the oxidation state of
carbon
and of oxygen in order to carry out this
reaction oxygen is a better electron
acceptor
than carbon and so transferring those
electrons
from the carbon to the oxygen is
favorable that is
in essence what is going on in this very
favorable reaction
to burn wood let me illustrate that
in a bit more explicitly here
so the carbon most of the carbons and
carbohydrates
are alcohols okay
so here you can call this our
carbohydrate okay with the exception
of the ketone or the aldehyde if it's a
ketose or an aldose
all the other carbons in the sugar are
alcohols okay
all the other bonds there and so if we
oxidize
that carbon that is if we remove
electrons from the carbon how can we do
that
okay so this here
generates this h
minus hydride ion this is in essence
two electrons that we are removing from
the carbon
okay that gives us a ketone
so if we oxidize the alcohol we remove
two electrons
we get the ketone
we could oxidize this ketone further
that will give us the carboxylic acid
if we oxidize it even further
now we get co2
okay so moving
in this direction this
is oxidation
transferring electrons from the carbon
to the oxygen to go in this oxidation
direction
that is glucose oxidation it's what's
happening when we're
burning wood it's what happens when we
burn glucose
energy is released
this is largely what catabolism
is about in biological
systems now it then
reasons then that if we're going to move
in the opposite direction
so-called reduction that is
okay going in this direction
reduction
that's largely energy
storage
or anabolism
in metabolism we are storing energy
that we can burn later and of course
what's the
more extreme version of this well what
if we add two more electrons to the
carbon going in this direction
okay well what do we end up with well
now we end up
with the saturated
carbon okay more reduced than the
alcohol is the fully saturated carbon
you'll see later that this is what fat
is you saw that in some of the earlier
lectures
it's also what gasoline is right what's
gasoline it's
fully saturated hydrocarbons that we
then burn
to co2 and derive energy
just like burning wood burning gasoline
all in one step oxidizing the gasoline
gives you
energy there's more energy and gasoline
you can release more energy per weight
from gasoline from fully saturated
hydrocarbons than you can from wood
same thing happening here what is more
calories in your food everyone knows
fat has more calories per weight than
sugar it's because the more reduced
our carbon is the more energy it stores
and as we oxidize that carbon that is
what
releases the energy and so
energy transduction in biological
systems
and actually in non-biological systems
as i just illustrated with the wood and
gasoline example but definitely in
biological systems
is largely about oxidation
and reduction reactions and you are
going to see this
coming up over and over again
now based on what i just said
the real magic if you will of glycolysis
can be further refined to say
that what glycolysis does is it couples
the favorable oxidation of carbon
with reactions that allow
phosphate addition and production of
intermediates like pep and one 3
bisphosphoglycerate
where synthesis of atp is favored
despite the high atp adp ratio in cells
if you think about it that process then
allows you to keep that atp adp ratio in
the range
where it can then be useful for all the
reasons we've been talking about now for
two lectures
allows a cell to couple that adp adp
ratio that an atp hydrolysis
to otherwise carry out otherwise
unfavorable
reactions okay so
based on that arguably
the key or at least a very important
reaction in glycolysis
is the oxidation step which happens to
add
the phosphate and also happens to make
1 3-bisphosphoglycerate which we saw
earlier can be used
to drive atp synthesis and so that
reaction is the following
so this molecule hopefully looks
familiar to you from the
carbohydrate lectures this is d
glyceraldehyde
three phosphate i will abbreviate it
frequently as g3p
for glyceraldehyde 3-phosphate but it's
d glyceraldehyde 3-phosphate remember
it's a d sugar because the
oh group is pointing to the right as we
drew it this way it's also an aldose
because it's a aldehyde sugar and it's
phosphorylated on the three position
remember the way we numbered
sugars was starting at the carbonyl one
two
three this is carbon three
phosphorylated on the three position
glyceraldehyde three phosphate
okay so this step
generates
one three bis phosphoglycerate
well to do this there's actually two
things that
happened here first we had to add
the phosphate to this that says two
phosphates on it bisphosphoglycerate
this has a single phosphate
so inorganic phosphate has to be added
to generate that molecule
by the way adding that phosphate
delta g not prime is positive plus 1.5 k
cals per mole
that means even at equilibrium this
reaction would lie to the left of course
because delta g not prime is
positive however remember the next step
downstream of this is the one shown over
here
where we do atp synthesis that step is
very favorable
so this is an example where metabolism
has coupled a very favorable step
to a step that's less favorable that can
keep the 1-3 bpg levels low
and pull the entire system forward the
metabolic trick we discussed in the last
lecture okay you'll note the other thing
that's happening here
other than adding that phosphate group
is that we've changed this aldehyde
to a carboxylic acid
that is an oxidation reaction
ketone to the acid is an oxidation
reaction i will illustrate over here
this so you can see why it's an
oxidation reaction
so here's our aldehyde if we take
electrons from the carbon
okay and that generates this
hydride ion two electrons
what are we left with well we're left
with
this intermediate that will never exist
with a positive charge on the carbon
water which of course is abundant in
biological systems
can then come
okay and it basically illustrates that
as i go
from the aldehyde to the acid
of course i make a proton and a hydride
ion but really i've changed the
oxidation state of the carbon
from the ketone to the to the acid state
two electrons are lost there is shown
as that hydride ion okay
so what does that mean well that means
that we have to maintain
that balance in this reaction as well
all right so water is going to have to
come in
and a proton will be produced but the
key thing
is we also generate two electrons
this hydride ion that have to go
somewhere
now finding a place for those
two electrons to go is
what brings up the second high level
concept
that i now need to spend some time
discussing
and the second high level concept that i
need to introduce
is the role of cofactors
and cofactors also is effectively the
role of
vitamins
and what role that these things play in
metabolism most vitamins
are used to support metabolic reactions
and we're going to learn all about what
many of the vitamins that you guys are
familiar with reading the side of your
cereal box
actually do throughout the course
now cofactors as i said often involve
vitamins
are molecules
that provide useful chemical groups
that facilitate the reaction chemistries
that are needed in metabolism
so they provide some useful chemical
groups
to facilitate
some of the chemistries that we need to
carry out metabolic
reactions they are in general
in small
non-stoichiometric
quantities in order to carry out this
function
what do i mean by that meaning that you
can imagine that the cell will convert
lots of
glyceraldehyde 3-phosphate to 1-3
bisphosphoglycerate
but the enzyme you don't need one enzyme
for every time
you convert that reaction the same
enzyme can do it over and over and over
again
well it turns out cofactors are much
more like enzymes in that respect
they need to be recycled in a way that
they can catalyze the turnover
reaction many many many times and it'll
be much clearer what i mean by this when
we get into some of the details
now the vitamin concept comes from the
fact that often
these cofactors
or parts of the cofactors
are not made by
animals not made by humans
if they're not made by us but we need
them to do our metabolism
well now we have to get them from the
diet and this is really
the concept of vitamins right these are
small things that we
have to get in quantities from the diet
and it turns out they're very important
to help us carry out
the metabolism we do as an aside the
vitamin industry is a very big business
lots of unfounded claims out there
i'm not going to get into that can get
very political i'm just going to say
that
just know that more is not always better
and
the goal for this class is really to
understand what some of these
vitamins actually do
okay now the relevant cofactor for the
reaction that
we're talking about is a cofactor
called nicotinamide adenine dinucleotide
which is always abbreviated nad or nad
plus
so this stands for nicotinamide
adenine
dinucleotide see why we want to
abbreviate that
nad and basically what
nicotinamide adenine dinucleotide is is
it's a cofactor
that can solve our problem of where to
put these electrons in this
oxidation reaction that is
it can accept two electrons
from a reaction like this one here
and cycle to another form of the
cofactor
called nadh all right
what is nicotinamide adenine
dinucleotide well first let's draw
what it looks like
uh
okay sorry it's squeezed down here a
little bit
so this here is adenine
this group up here is nicotinamide
so if you look at this this is a
dinucleotide
and so down here this of course is
from here down is amp that phosphate is
now
over here this is a separate nucleotide
where rather than having one of the
agctu
bases that you're used to from rna and
dna nicotinamide is the base
and so it's this amp
plus this nicotinamide base as a
monophosphate
or a nicotinamide adenine dinucleotide
this the nicotinamide group okay
is derived from
a vitamin called niacin and so from the
side of your cereal box this is what
niacin does it allows you
to generate the nicotinamide group
that's part of this cofactor
nicotinamide adenine dinucleotide
now nicotinamide adenine dinucleotide
is useful because of what that
nicotinamide group
can do and so i'm not going to draw out
the whole molecule
but i'll show you so nad plus which is
the oxidized
form of nicotinamide adenine
dinucleotide
is as i drew it up there
okay so this here would be attached to
the rest of the dinucleotide
okay so this is the oxidized form
i can have
here's my hydride ion which remember is
two electrons
if i carry out that chemistry to add
those two electrons to the
nicotinamide group
you now end up with the
reduced form
of nicotinamide adenine nucleotide nadh
so the difference between nad plus
and nadh it's the h but it's really the
two electrons that were added
in adding that h so
it's oxidized form and reduced form
all right so remember i want to stress
this again
at least in biology we can't create or
destroy matter
you can do that in nuclear physics but
we can't do that in
biology and so that means that if we do
an electron transfer
like we did in this reaction where we
oxidized
the aldehyde in glyceraldehyde
3-phosphate to the acid
in 1-3 bisphosphoglycerate those
electrons have to be
accounted for and so if one molecule is
oxidized
another one has to be reduced so redox
reactions
always i this redox oxidation reduction
reactions
always have to happen in pairs and so
over there we have the aldehyde in
glyceraldehyde
3-phosphate
is oxidized
to form the acid
in one three bisphosphoglycerate
all right as part of that reaction
we can couple it such that the
nicotinamide group
which is oxidized in nad can be reduced
to the nicotinamide group that is found
in nadh
okay so that means we can draw
this in here is that
having that cofactor coupled to this
reaction
now allows us to fix the redox problem
of this reaction now
this reaction here is catalyzed
by an enzyme
called glycerol 3-phosphate
dehydrogenase i'll draw that out in a
second
often abbreviated
gap dh the loading control on all of
your western blots
is the enzyme gap dh glyceraldehyde
phosphate dehydrogenase
that is the enzyme that carries out
that reaction now notice the name fits
it's a
dehydrogenase it's removing a hydrogen
removing two electrons as a hydride ion
but it's really what's important here is
the electrons moving
not the hydrogen itself so in that way
it's a little bit
misleading and you will see that in
general
dehydrogenases are classes of enzymes
that catalyze oxidation reduction
reactions
and as a result often involve nad nadh
as cofactors because they facilitate
those electron transfer reactions
okay so now we're able to describe how
gap dh
works in great detail
and so
the chemistry of gap dh works as follows
and so
in the active site of gap dh
there's a cysteine residue that cysteine
residue
has a sulfur shown here also bound
near the active site is an nad molecule
to catalyze the reaction
um shown that nad has to be in the
oxidized state so it's nad plus
and so glyceraldehyde
3-phosphate in the active site
okay
there's glyceraldehyde 3-phosphate
by the way i will show you
how many reactions in metabolism work
chemically obviously we don't have time
in this class and overview class to go
into all the great chemical details of
what's going on and exactly how this how
everything works but
at least try to give you a flavor of
some of the chemistry that happens
throughout the course all right so once
you have then
okay so now you have this intermediate
bound into the enzyme active site
you can now carry out
the oxidation of that carbon
so these are two electrons
being removed as a hydride ion they can
be transferred to nad in the
active site that generates nadh by the
exact chemistry that
i just showed you
okay that nadh now needs to be
exchanged out or
the enzyme will not be able to
catalyze the next series of reactions
and that nadh will then go somewhere
else and of course has to be cycled back
to nad but that doesn't happen
in this reaction per se
okay next
this here you'll notice is that by
the way this chemistry worked we formed
this thioester
bond in the active site this is another
thing that you will see
over and over again in metabolism this
sulfur in the thioester bond is a good
leaving group
and so it's really setting up a
situation that will now help with the
phosphate addition so here i'll draw out
inorganic phosphate
and that of course will give us
the identical enzyme active site that we
started with
plus
one three bisphosphoglycerate
and that 1 3 bisphosphoglycerate can now
be coupled
to atp synthesis to make
3-phosphoglycerate and so you can see
in essence what this reaction has done
is that it has coupled oxidation
of the aldehyde to the acid the aldehyde
and three phosphoglycerate
to the acid in one three
bisphosphoglycerate
which can then do phosphorylation of adp
to make atp
so in essence this is oxidative
phosphorylation
i realize in high school or in other
classes oxidative phosphorylation means
something different to you and of course
we will discuss
the process that is called oxidative
phosphorylation in great detail later in
this course
but i want to point out that the
chemistry that's actually happening here
in glycolysis
is also oxidative phosphorylation
it's basically how you coupled this
favorable carbon oxidation
that's occurring at this gap dh step in
a way that allows you
to synthesize atp at a high atp adp
ratio
which in the end will allow cells to do
otherwise
unfavorable things okay
now we're ready to discuss
these reactions the gap dh reaction the
pyruvate kinase reaction
the phosphoglycerate kinase reaction and
how they fit into glycolysis
as a metabolic pathway in a way that
allows cells to use
glucose catabolism that is the breakdown
of glucose the burning of glucose
as a way to get energy and that pathway
is of course
glycolysis or glucose lysis that we
mentioned
earlier glycolysis is a very ancient
and ubiquitous pathway it's used by
essentially
all life on earth and probably has been
for at least two to three billion years
glycolysis i guess is a pathway was
quote unquote discovered
mid 19th century by louis pasteur and
louis pasteur of course
described life microorganisms as being
responsible for the process of
fermentation
that is conversion of glucose into
alcohol something
many college students are interested in
as well as
other organic acids and of course
fermentation
to make alcohol or to store
other types of of you know to organic
acids has been used in
food preservation for centuries which is
really why pasteur's discoveries were so
impactful at the time now even though
pasteur discovered this he didn't really
understand chemically how it worked and
it actually took decades to
figure that out and when it was finally
figured out and described as the pathway
called glycolysis
this was done by two chemists to
chemists in germany emdin and meyerhoff
and basically what they did is they
pieced together
several enzymatic or chemical activities
that have been purified
from cell lysates mostly from yeast
and used those to build a pathway that
described
chemically how you could start with
glucose
and chemically break down that glucose
in a way that made sense
in this fermentation pathway and that
is why glycolysis is sometimes called
the
emdin meyerhoff pathway
now glycolysis does not completely
convert glucose
to co2 instead what glycolysis does
is it converts glucose
which i will draw here in the pyranose
form it converts glucose
by a number of steps into two molecules
of the organic acid pyruvate
which of course was the product
of that pyruvate kinase reaction that we
showed
earlier
note that the fermentation that louis
pasteur described
was further metabolism of that pyruvate
into something else okay in the case of
yeast
it was ethanol or
ethyl alcohol
or something else the fermentative
product
in mammals
is this organic acid lactate
and what we will see next time is that
this fermentation of pyruvate into one
of these other molecules
ends up being an alternative to the
further oxidation of pyruvate
to co2 which requires oxygen and the
reason
oxidizing pyruvate to co2 requires
oxygen
is because ultimately we have to
regenerate that nadh we made in
glycolysis
to allow that cofactor to cycle and
glycolysis to keep
moving fermentation gives us an
alternative way to do this which we'll
discuss in great
detail in the next lecture but first i
want to focus
on glycolysis
and what we can describe next time is
really how we can build a pathway to
turn glucose into pyruvate this
glycolysis is emdin myerhof pathway
and some of the details of that pathway
are shown here
on this slide and this is where we'll
start off
the next lecture discussing how each of
these steps in glycolysis function in a
way
that allow a pathway to generate
phospholinopyruvate 1 3
bisphosphoglycerate
incorporate this gap dh reaction
and do so in a way that's overall
energetically favorable
to allow the cell to couple this
oxidation of glucose
to keeping atp adp ratio
in the right range to support other
unfavorable functions
in the cell okay thanks